you change the future
and you change the past
are you in
Happy new year everyone i've gotten a lot
of requests to do a video about the flash
movie rebooting the dc eu the justice league so
i'll explain what's going on with that because i
think some of the details are getting mixed up in
translation but if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos there's
a bunch of big dc stuffed dc movies happening this
year like the batman movie with robert pattinson
is the next big movie we're getting in march
speaking of the multiverse because the flash movie
is kind of like their first major multiverse movie
even though crisis on infinite earths with the
dc tv shows kind of already gave us a version of
multiverse with ezra miller's justice league
flash crossing over with grant gustin's dctv
flash but you've probably seen people in your
timelines talking about a report that's been
circulating about the flash movie going full
flash point way more than we originally thought
a couple years ago after the big debacle with
the justice league theatrical version i joked
that they should just use the flash movie to
reboot everything so they could pretend like
that theatrical version never happened now we
did get the snyder cut which kind of replaces
the theatrical cut but it does sound like the
actual flash movie we're getting later this year
has a plan to soft reboot or re-tune some
of the elements in the characters in the
dceu i think some of the details about this
quote-unquote reboot are a little exaggerated
but i'll try to explain what's going on just based
on what ezra miller recently said about them not
decanonizing anything and what the producers
and the director have said about them trying to
canonize pretty much everything you've ever seen
in the dc universe through the multiverse so first
things first the flash movie is doing a version of
flashpoint but it's not the exact same story from
the comics the movie story is original and they're
just inspired by some elements from flashpoint
like the altering of the timeline the alternate
versions of the characters the flash movies sort
of combining a multiverse movie like spider-man
no way home and a time travel flashpoint story
like imagine the marvel people combining the loki
series with all the time travel and the alternate
versions of characters with spider-man no way home
which is different characters from other universes
so in the way that we've started to call the mcu
the marvel cinematic multiverse after the loki
series spider-man into the spider-verse spider-man
no way home with these multiverse characters and
doctor strange multiverse abandons the dc people
the warner brothers people the directors have
said that they're pretty much doing the same thing
with the flash movie like now they're referring to
the dc eu as the larger dc multiverse you may have
heard them talking about this when they did their
big dc fandom presentations this past year and
then back in 2020 talking about the dc multiverse
so like marvel just canonized the events of the
tobey maguire spider-man movies in the andrew
garfield amazing spider-man movies to the mcu dc
will basically be doing that for michael keaton's
batman movies in the flash movie but they also
posted a trailer back in 2020 where they included
footage from the christopher reeve superman movie
the classic wonder woman series pretty much all
the movies and the tv shows that dc has done from
the last 40 years or more so that's what i mean
when they're starting to refer to things as the
dc multiverse instead of just the straight up dceu
up to this point we've only thought of the dceu
as the movies based on the zack snyder versions
of the characters like the current justice league
roster in all their solo movies that also included
both of the suicide squad movies like the new one
as well and the new john cena peacemaker series
so that's why you just have to think of it as
the larger dc multiverse now even though people
will just continue to use the term mcu and dceu
just because that's become such shorthand for a
way of describing the current crop of movies i did
a flash movie trailer video after they released
the last one at dc fandom but we learned that ezra
miller's main flash travels to the universe where
michael keaton's batman came from call it earth 89
whatever you want basically the earth from the tim
burton batman movies and there he encounters an
alternate universe barry allen flash and creates a
lo-fi homemade version of a flash suit with a lot
of red death easter eggs because zoom in enhance
you can see his flash suit is just a scrap version
of one of michael keaton batman's old batman suits
like he literally just spray paints red over an
old keaton batman suit so i say red death easter
eggs because that's kind of the vibe here red
death was a dragon ball fusion style speedster
created when a version of batman uses the speed
force to merge with the version of baryon and
his costume was kind of like a combo batman flash
mashup like this there's also the low-key rumors
that this alternate version of barry allen will
wind up being one of the villains of the movie
because they also just confirmed that a version
of michael shannon's zod and feora from man of
steel are coming back for the flash movie they
might be villains maybe not but it seems like
they're in the movie just based on casting reports
i say they might not be villains because the whole
beauty of flashpoint is that some of the major
villains are good in the alternate timeline and
some of the heroes are villains in the whole
idea of flashpoint is the flash learning that
he can't play god and use his abilities to change
the timeline for selfish reasons michael keaton's
batman has that speech in the trailer where he
sounds like he's taking flash to task about that
you changed the past you changed the future
but the reports about them rebooting the dceu
are that they'll end the movie with a new main
universe justice league roster with supergirl like
this version of supergirl and michael keaton's
batman replacing ben affleck's batman and henry
cavill superman is the main versions you see in
all the future crossover justice league movies
it should go without saying that the new roster
the next time they do a justice league movie will
also include characters like shazam but i'm mostly
just talking about them swapping out characters in
this video so here's where i think there's a lot
of confusion because when you see people posting
about how they're getting rid of ben affleck's
batman and henry cavill superman i think that's
a little exaggerated people were worried that dc
was just gonna completely erase all the continuity
of the zack snyder justice league films and those
spin-off movies i think that the warner brothers
and the dc people know how many people would just
openly revolt if they saw something like that
like if they actually tried to show up and say no
no this never happened but i think for sure yes
they are trying to change the main justice
league roster going forward they'd have to
do it eventually like eventually some of these
actors will say okay you know i'm done i'm not
gonna do this anymore like clockwork almost every
six to eight years we always get a new batman
if you've been around since back in the day
you've already seen many many alternate versions
of superman and batman and right now ben affleck
has said he doesn't really want to do any more
batman like he's not really interested in doing
giant franchise movies anymore so the flash movie
was kind of supposed to be his last appearance as
the character no matter what and they've already
started working on like 10 different versions
of superman in the dc movies already so henry
cavill seemed like he was going to get a couple
last hurrahs and then he'd move on eventually too
but the way they'll probably handle this from a
multiverse continuity perspective because they're
trying to use the movie to canonize a bunch
of other classic versions of the characters
to the dceu is they'll just use the blanket broad
multiverse explainer just like hand wave and say
they're creating a multiverse version of the
justice league without having to totally erase
ben affleck's batman and henry cavill superman or
any other characters in the future that they want
to cycle in and out of justice league rosters if
some of the majors like batman superman eventually
wonder woman aren't going to stick around
for forever you do need to explain how to add
other versions to the main team because they're
always going to want to have a version of batman
on the team they're always going to want to have a
version of superman could you imagine them trying
to do a justice league movie without a version of
batman on the team and marvel just did a great job
with spider-man no way home so i'll say spoiler
warning for spider-man no way home if you haven't
seen that movie yet because some of the twists
it sounds like they're going to be using in the
dc universe to explain what's going on with all
these character swaps right now sony has a billion
spider-man spin-off movies they're developing like
the venom movies the morbius movies sinister six
solo movies and they want spider-man in those
as much as possible in as many ways as possible
but tom holland mcu spider-man doesn't want to
do a billion new spider-man movies by bringing
back topi maguire and andrew garfield spider-man
in spider-man no way home they basically setting
up the idea that eventually you will start seeing
other multiverse versions of spider-man showing
up in some of these other sony movies and it won't
feel weird for all the filthy casuals that aren't
like big comic book fans because they already
justified the logic through spider-man no way home
like oh there are a bunch of other versions of
these characters out there in the multiverse
like sony does a bunch of other movies and they
bring andrew garfield spider-man back for that
while you still have tom holland doing the mcu
spider-man movies so i think that's why the
flash movie will take a similar approach with the
multiverse versions of all these justice league
characters like everything is canon now kind of
and it will give them the flexibility they need
to mix and match teams in the future so that
down the road if they really want to go crazy
and do a crisis on infinite earth's movie like
a much bigger version than we saw in the dc tv
crisis on infinite earths they can bring back
henry cavill superman or bring back henry cavill
as alternate versions of a different superman in
some movies and it will all make sense same thing
with ben affleck's batman if he wants to come back
in 20 years as a different batman beyond version
of bruce wayne which is kind of what they're doing
with michael keaton's batman right now that's why
you probably heard michael keaton is going to be
showing up in the batgirl movie in other movies
beyond that as sort of like a multiverse crossover
batman so yes they are probably going to cycle the
justice league roster with different versions
of the characters i think the thing people are
getting wrong though is that they're not erasing
the other versions of those characters like henry
cavill superman and ben affleck's batman the whole
reason why robert pattinson's batman is set during
a different universe is because matt reeves just
didn't want to have to deal with all the other
crossover continuity like he just wanted to tell
a batman story and didn't want to worry about
the other stuff but long term there's always the
idea that eventually if robert pattinson wanted
to and if matt reeves was open to it they could
also use him in a big multiverse crossover story
so never say never you just have to imagine
they're going to get way crazier with the way they
use alternate versions of characters using tropes
like the multiverse and time travel big reminder
though my star wars book of boba fett episode 2
video will post this wednesday just like normal
in the dc peacemaker hbo episodes we'll start
in a couple weeks too i will be doing episode
videos for that and that is connected to the dc
eu everyone click here for my new morbius trailer
video and learn how that's connected to spider-man
no way home and andrew garfield spider-man and
click here to learn how they changed the timelines
of the tobey maguire and andrew garfield movies
at the end of no way home thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and happy new year!